I used to put 35% food grade 100 proxide in the water.
I built up extremely slowly to 10 to 12 to 14 drops daily in 12 hours in the water.
Once a day on an empty stomach, many people discourage this, but is there value in this?
So I did your proxide is an oxidizing agent.
So either proxide can be great if you can get it to the cancer.
So in your case, asking this question with colon cancer, you have a lot better chance taking
it orally, getting it to the cancer than you do if you find a cancer in the liver or
in the lungs or in the breast or in the brain.
Hydrogen proxide is not going to stay as hydrochroxide and absorb it into your blood surface.
Hydrogen proxide is going to change if it's going to affect the benefit.
Probably the best use of hydrogen proxide orally would be for a stomach cancer.
You probably need much better option to try to get hydrochroxide directly into the cancer
or colon cancer if you're in a liver.
So again, when you take something orally that can kill cancer directly, you have to go,
I have to get it to the cancer orally to the cancer.
Is it going to change physiologically in the stomach?
Is it going to be absorbed?
Is it going to break down?
The answer is yes.
I really don't think the hydrochroxide taking it away is going to get to your colon and
it's going to start to grow outside.
You'd have to do it as it gets in the blood.
That's where people will take baking soda to alkalize their body.
Well, really, you're only alkalizing your stomach and I want to alkalize the cancer.
Well, let's get a stomach cancer, it's not going to really help.
Maybe you stop a deal and certainly maybe do want a little cancer, but beyond that, it's
going to be broken down.